SIGNIFYING NOTHING.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
TODAY THE DEMOCRATS ENGAGED IN A
BIT OF THEATER IN A DESPERATE
EFFORT TO KEEP THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION DRAMA GOING.
JERROLD NADLER'S COMMITTEE ALONG
PARTY LINE VOTED TO SUBPOENA THE
ENTIRE UNREDACTED REPORT.
ALL SUPPORTING EVIDENCE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> THEY STILL REFUSE THAT IT
SHOULD BE UP TO A JUDGE AND NOT
THE PRESIDENT AND NOT AS
POLITICAL APPOINTEE.
DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT IT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
REVIEW THE COMPLETE RECORD.
>> Laura: UNDERSTAND THIS, BUT
THIS MOVE, HE IS COMMITTING A
FRAUD.
IT IS A FRAUD THAT IS FILED AT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ON THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND A
DISCUSSION OF IT, A FRAUD ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ANY JUDGE CONSIDERING THIS
SHOULD SANCTION ANY LAWYER WHO
SIGNS HIS NAME ON THIS REQUEST
FOR A SUBPOENA GIVEN THAT THE
LAW PROHIBITS ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR FROM RELEASING
UNDERLYING MATERIAL WITHOUT A
CAREFUL REVIEW FOR ANY GRAND
JURY INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE
PROHIBITED BY LAW TO RELEASE.
>> HE IS FOR BIDEN FROM
PROVIDING GRAND JURY FROM
LIMITED EXCEPTIONS.
THEY ARE NOT ONE AND THE
CHAIRMAN KNOWS IT.
>> Laura: THIS IS A SHOW.
NEVER MIND THAT HE FOUND NO
CRIMINALITY IN HIS TWO YEAR
PROBE AND THAT THERE IS NOTHING
IN THE REPORT TO JUSTIFY
IMPEACHMENT WHICH IS WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DISTRACT FROM
THEIR OWN EMBARRASSMENT AND FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC SERIES TO BE
CORRECT, BILL BARR AND
INTERNATIONALLY RESPECTFUL OF
MIND AND THE FORMER BUSH
ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD'VE HAD TO
KNOWINGLY DISTORT MUELLER'S
FINDING ON COLLUSION AND
INSTRUCTION.
TWO, EVERYBODY INVOLVED IN THIS
INVESTIGATION WOULD HAVE TO BE
IN SOME WAY IN CAHOOTS, WORKING
TO PROTECT THE PRESIDENT AT ALL
COSTS.
TONIGHT WE HAVE REPORTS IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THAT THERE
ARE ANONYMOUS INVESTIGATORS FROM
THE MUELLER TEAM WHO FEEL LIKE A
SUMMARY WASN'T COMPLETE.
THE REPORT DOESN'T SAY WHO WAS
UPSET OR WHAT THEY ARE UPSET
ABOUT, IT IS KIND OF MURKY.
WHY WOULD MUELLER TO STANDBY
WITHOUT OBJECTION IF BARR HAD
SKEWED IN HIS LENGTHY FINDING?
400 PAGE REPORT, A FOUR PAGE
SUMMARY.
THE ANSWER, MUELLER WENT TO
THAT.
IT ONLY TOOK HIM HOURS TO
CORRECT A FALSE REPORT FROM BUZZ
FEET EARLIER THIS YEAR AND ALSO
REMEMBER, BOTH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS WENT TO GREAT PAIN TO
BUILD HIM UP.
AN UPSTANDING CITIZEN AND LEGAL
MIND.
>> HE CHOSE MUELLER WHO HAS SO
MUCH INTEGRITY.
>> THERE IS LITERALLY NO MORE
RESPECTABLE PERSON.
>> JUDGMENT, INTEGRITY.
IF YOU DESPAIR THAT IS NOT A
HERO IN AMERICA, WAKE UP BECAUSE
ROBERT MUELLER IS IT.
>> THE REPUBLIC GOT A CHANCE OF
SAVING ITSELF.
>> Laura: NOT TO BELIEVE THAT
THE SAINTED FIGURE HAS BECOME
EITHER MUZZLED OR IN SOME WAY
MANIPULATED?
FAT CHANCE.
EVEN NOW BILL BARR IS WORKING TO
REDACT THE REPORT IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE LAW AND ORDER TO
RELEASE IT AS PROMISED PROBABLY
BY MID-APRIL.
WHY ARE THE DEMOCRATS IN A RUSH?
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
THEY ARE SO INVESTED IN THIS
GRAND TINFOIL HAT CONSPIRACY
THAT THEY HAVE FORGOTTEN HOW TO
GOVERN.
THEY FORGOTTEN HOW TO CHARGE
ISSUES SUCH AS THIS, VERY
IMPORTANT.
HATRED FOR TRUMP, THROUGH
ANIMATING PRINCIPLE AND THEY
MUST CONSTANTLY FEED THEIR MEDIA
AND POLITICAL BEAST.
BEASTS WHO HAVE BEEN SHARPENING
THEIR TEETH TO DEVOUR TRUMP
SINCE THE NIGHT OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
I THINK IN THIS TWISTED WORLD OF
RESISTANCE, IT DOESN'T MATTER IF
THE CASE AGAINST TRUMP
EVAPORATED.
THEY WILL CREATE ANOTHER ONE.
THEY ARE ADDICTED TO HATING
TRUMP.
RECALL HOW HIGH WITH
ANTICIPATION THEY HAVE BEEN.
>> WE ARE SEEING THAT THE
COLLUSION PIECE OF THIS STARTING
TO BE BUILT OUT.
>> A POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT
FOR HER.
WE WILL CALL IT HURRICANE
VLADIMIR IF YOU WILL.
>> HE IS LASHING OUT.
>> THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN ON
PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: THEY ARE CLOSING IN
ON RIGHT BUT NOT ON TRUMP.
NOW THE MEDIA WILL DO ANYTHING
TO AVOID KICKING THEIR HATE
TRUMP HABIT.
DEMOCRATIC MEDIA AND
COCONSPIRATORS ARE SEEING THEIR
RATINGS COLLAPSE, BUT THEY
REJECT THE IDEA THAT AN
INTERVENTION IS IN ANY WAY
NECESSARY.
THEY ARE ON A PATH OF
SELF-DESTRUCTION >> COLLUSION IS
A BEHAVIOR AND THERE COULD BE
AMPLE PROOF OF THAT KIND OF BEHV
AMPLE PROOF OF THAT KIND OF BEHO
AMPLE PROOF OF THAT KIND OF BEHR
AMPLE PROOF OF THAT KIND OF BEHA
AMPLE PROOF OF THAT KIND OF BEHD
MUELLER'S FINDING.
>> A POLITICAL BATTLE WITH HIS
PERCEPTION THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS TRYING TO SHIELD US FROM
INFORMATION FROM THE PUBLIC.
>> IT FEELS THAT THE SEEDS OF A
COVER UP OUR HERO.
>> Laura: HE FLAMES OF
CONSPIRACY MUST BE KEPT BURNING.
THE RESISTANCE EUPHORIA THAT WAS
ONCE SO EXHILARATING.
YESTERDAY CNN AND MSNBC FOUND A
TRULY SENSATIONAL NEW MORSEL FOR
THEIR AUDIENCES.
>> YOU WERE SAYING HE DOES NOT
ONLY CHEATS, HE CHEATS!
HE CHEATS ON ALL OF IT!
>> HE CHEATS LIKE A MAFIA
ACCOUNTANT.
HE TRIED TO CHEAT TIGER WOODS IN
A MATCH.
FOUR BALLS ON THE POCKET AND
THEY WILL THROW IT OUT OF ANY
BUNKER.
ARNOLD PALMER WOULD BE ROLLING
IN HIS GRAVE.
>> Laura: GULF GATE COME
HILARIOUS.
AGAIN, IT REALLY ISN'T.
THE IDEA THAT POLITICAL AND
MEDIA PARTISANS SHOULD WORK THIS
HARD TO GREAT AND ANTI-TRUMP
NARRATIVE, EVEN AS DEFECTS
ESCAPE THEM.
IT IS TRAGIC, SO WHAT NEXT?
WHAT THE PRESIDENTS DIET TELLS
US ABOUT HIS PRESIDENCY, OR
AIR FORCE ONE, WHAT IS UNDER
TRUMP SMALL-CAP AND WHY IT
SHOULD CONCERN YOU?
ACTIVIST FROM DOZENS OF FAR LEFT
GROUPS ARE PROMISING, MASSIVE
PROTESTS NASCENT MIKE
NATIONWIDE.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP IT GOING.
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE?
ANYONE WITH A BRAIN KNOWS IT IS
ABOUT COLLECTING EMAIL
ADDRESSES, BUT WHAT THEY CLAIM
TO BE PROTESTS TOMORROW WILL BE
ABOUT IS THAT THEY WANT TO
PRESSURE BILL BARR TO RELEASE
THE ENTIRE UNREDACTED REPORT AND
ALL THE UNDERLYING'S INTERVIEWS
AND SO FORTH.
IF BARR OR ANY ATTORNEY GENERAL
BOW TO SOME ORGANIZE PROTEST AND
ABANDON IN THE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, HE OR SHE WOULD
RISK SERIOUS LEGAL JEOPARDY.
WHO CARES?
THE CONCEPTS OF THE RULE OF LAW
MEAN NOTHING TO THESE PEOPLE
WHOSE SOLE PURPOSE AND LIFE IS
TO RESIST TRUMP BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
TOMORROW ALONG WITH THEIR
RELEASE REPORTS SIGN, THE
ORGANIZERS SHOULD BE PASSING OUT
TINFOIL HATS MY QUESTION IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THEY COME TO MIKE
RUN OUT OF CONSPIRACY THEORIES?